This is a pretty straightforward thing to write in Python.
Let's imagine that we've got a list L--I made a list which is the node centrality values
from one of the recent graph that I used as an example.
And we're going to define a subroutine mean that takes a list and initializes total to 0,
runs through all the elements in the list adding up their values,
and then returning the total divided by the length.
This really is just a straightforward application definition with this
kind of intermediate accumulative variable.
And so if we go and print the mean of this list, it calculates it as 2-2/3.
Here's that subroutine again just copied over, and I'd like you to answer the question
what is the running time of this little i with the mean.
Is it constant, log, linear and logn or quadratic.